was a little stressful i was just
overthinking the lines when i was
reading them
addison ray is addressing the big
mistakes she made while presenting at
the billboard music awards
earlier this month was a little
stressful because i did an outfit change
but it wasn't too bad because like we
had a minute to like actually put the
outfit on
and then once i did that went on stage
and then right before
it you had to read off of like the thing
you know like you could read off the
thing
and there was like words there so it
like i guess it like quite made me
question what i
had already was reading you know like on
from the paper
a little refresher during the awards
show the 20 year old tick tock star
presented the award for billboard chart
achievement to harry styles
and the billboard chart achievement
award goes to
harry styles but eagle-eyed fans were
quick to notice that she
never actually opened the envelope with
the watermelon sugar singer's name on it
yes so she clearly knew who the winner
was beforehand
i was just overthinking the lines when i
was reading them and then
like did i say that already yeah and
then it just was like throwing me off
and i was like oh gosh i don't even know
where i am right now
and then also there's like no one in
this big
theater so it's like scary looking
because there's no one in it but you're
like talking
and you know the camera's on you and
like rolling live now addison's
addressing the mishap on her podcast
mama knows best on the prompter it
didn't say like
open envelope it just said no it didn't
say that
it literally just said and the award
goes to dot dot dot dot
and then it says announce winner in like
parentheses so i just like announced i
just said it
and i didn't even think twice about like
opening the envelope which is obviously
the whole point did they tell you how to
open them
yeah okay but i just wasn't thinking
about it because i was reading it
because i was nervous
look things happen we all get nervous
and guys she did her best to prep i am
going to
read over what i am saying at the
billboard awards tonight i wrote this
and so
this is nerve-wracking and scary so yeah
i'm going to read over this for like
45 minutes so y'all can just sit here
for 40 minutes and watch me addison
vlogged about her first ever billboard
music awards and shared a whole lot of
behind-the-scenes footage
including her practicing for that now
infamous moment
and the billboard chart achievement
award goes to
and then it cuts to me being like balala
harry styles
addison previously poked fun at the
incident on instagram
sharing some shots from the evening
alongside the caption
after the show last night i learned how
to open an envelope
gotta love that she has a sense of humor
about all of it and when e.t caught up
with addison and her mama sherry last
month
she shared the best advice she's been
given since achieving
mega stardom never let it get to the
point where you're just not enjoying it
and try to
really take in every moment that you
have presented to you and
um take it like it's your last one and
just make it the best life is so short
so why not just really take advantage of
everything and
do everything that makes you happy now
while you can what about
for mom how has it been to watch her
career and her star sort of grow
so so big over the past few months it's
been really
crazy and amazing and i just
i'm so proud of her really oh that's so
sweet
i haven't heard that one yet so thank
[Music]
you